what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios is
actually going to reboot the MCU now of
course they're not going to do this
right now it's happening after Avengers
Secret Wars or should I say in Avengers
Secret Wars and that's a little telling
about the movie it means that not
everything is going to go according to
the Avengers and other Heroes like the
X-Men and the Fantastic Four all the
other teams it's not going to go
according to their plans and at the end
of Kang Dynasty the heroes will most
likely lose and the Multiverse will
begin to essentially fall apart and
collapse and probably be under the
control of the Council of Kings and the
Kang Trio ramatut mortis and the Scarlet
Centurion then an Avengers Secret Wars
The Avengers might win along with the
other Heroes however that doesn't mean
they'll necessarily be able to restore
the damage that has been done and that
is where the MCU reboot comes in and
this new reboot could essentially get
rid of the Avengers which sounds crazy
but of course they're doing this to make
way for the X-Men and based off of
everything that we've heard so far about
Secret Wars it sounds like the Avengers
and some other characters are going to
get a pretty good send-off so we'll
break down what we hear is going to
happen during and at the end of Secret
Wars and how the new MCU will begin and
if you're new be sure to hit that
subscribe button so you don't miss out
on any of the latest MCU news we're also
doing a big giveaway right now we'll
talk more about that at the end so for a
few weeks now a lot of insiders have
talked about Secret Wars being a reboot
to the MCU once it is done now a lot of
people are wondering what that means is
this going to start the MCU completely
over from the beginning is everything
that has happened before from Iron Man
up until now going to be erased that's a
thought that can upset some people
understandably so I wouldn't want the
entirety of what we've already gotten in
the MCU to be erased but fortunately for
us it does not sound like that is going
to be the case from what we are hearing
from a lot of insiders this is going to
be a soft reboot so not everything is
going to be completely erased however
moving forward in the MCU things are
going to be pretty new in a way this is
kind of The Best of Both Worlds we get
to keep the past everything that we've
loved up until now but moving forward we
get a brand new future the recent report
coming from Insider can we get some
toast who stated on Twitter yesterday
yes Hugh Jackman won't be recast until
after Avengers Secret Wars now to touch
on that part real quick because we've
all been hearing about a new Wolverine
for the MCU being cast and shown to us
in Deadpool 3 what this tweet is
referring to is that Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine is going to be our main
Wolverine in the MCU until Secret Wars
it's not until after Secret Wars where a
new Wolverine will take the spotlight
yes we still might have a very good idea
of who the new Wolverine is in Deadpool
3 like some insiders have implied but
even if we do see the newly casted
Wolverine for the new MCU after Secret
Wars he will not come into play until
after Secret Wars in the meantime it is
going to remain huge Jackman as it
should because he's making an epic
return to his character Wolverine and
joining the MCU plus the new X-Men teams
aren't going to be established until
after Secret Wars anyways so it wouldn't
really make sense to have a new
Wolverine in the MCU right now but the
rest of the report from can we get some
toast States this feige is making secret
Wars the send-off to not only the
current MCU but all the Marvel movies
that come before Iron Man it's the the
ultimate soft reboot to make way for
something all new and all different now
if you understand what they are saying
here it's actually pretty awesome
because when they say it's going to be a
send-off not only to the current MCU but
all the Marvel movies that came before
Iron Man you know that that means we're
talking about everything from the first
X-Men movie to Spider-Man to Daredevil
with Ben Affleck and everything else in
between up until Iron Man and then from
Iron Man to Avengers end game to Secret
Wars so essentially Secret Wars is going
to give us a farewell and a send off to
everything that has literally happened
with Marvel before Secret Wars up to
Secret Wars which is crazy to think
about now we've known for a while that
Kevin feige wanted to do this he wanted
to bring back the original X-Men the
original Fantastic Four Ben Affleck's
Daredevil Elektra with Jennifer Garner
The Punisher with Thomas Jane Nick
Cage's Ghostwriter so on and so forth if
you think about everything that's come
before and you think about the
possibility of all of these old Legacy
characters being on screen with our new
MCU characters that's an absolutely
insane thought plus not to mention this
is the Multiverse and Secret Wars is all
about the Multiverse so there of course
is the possibility that these characters
can be on screen with Robert Downey Jr's
Iron Man with Chris Evans as Captain
America they can come back specifically
to be a part of this farewell now of
course they're going to be from Another
Universe but hopefully they would suit
up for the same character to give them a
proper goodbye and really it's a big
giant thank you thank you to everything
that has come before the MCU thank you
to the start and the foundation of the
MCU and everything that is led up to now
it's very poetic and is kind of Kevin
feige's Love Letter to everything to all
Marvel I love it I love the idea but let
me know what you think about it in the
comments down below now the future of
the MCU after Secret Wars after this
poetic goodbye could possibly be even
more insane than what we've already seen
we'll talk about that in just a bit but
first big thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video many of you may
know that I personally use hellofresh
and I love it it makes cooking fun easy
and it's affordable and that's why it's
America's number one meal kit delivered
straight to your door and you might not
know that they actually have seasonal
recipes right now since it's summer they
have their new fresh and fit summer menu
so if you're trying to get that beach
bud but you're also trying to eat really
great tasting food it's perfect for you
right now it's peak time for summer
produce and hellofresh make sure you get
all the best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days or quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now you can go to
hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic news code 50
Cosmic for 50 off plus 15 off the next
two months that's hellofresh.com 50
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50 off
plus 15 off the next two months
now for the future of the MCU starting
with what we're going to assume is Phase
seven but if they are doing a soft
reboot could go back and call it phase
one or possibly get rid of phases
altogether or maybe call it something
like Universe 2 or something like
Universe 900 phase one whatever it may
be the new start of the new MCU after
Secret Wars this will begin and
primarily focus on the X-Men and what
most of us assume it's going to be like
is The Avengers just like how the
Avengers started in phase one we assume
that the X-Men will basically begin the
same way why well because it worked it
worked with phase one it worked with
Iron Man Captain America Thor and yes
the Hulk even though was a different
Hulk but it also worked with the other
characters they introduced in these
movies that would go on to be a part of
the Avengers team like Akai and black
widow they introduced the individual
characters gave us their origin stories
they were brought together to form the
Avengers it was fantastic and if you
were there at the start of the MCU and
were old enough to go to the theaters at
that point in time and watch The
Avengers come together other in that
film you know how amazing it was this
model is pretty much perfect for a big
Ensemble team coming together so what we
hope and assume that phase seven or
phase one of a different universe is
going to be like is like phase one of
the MCU that we know and love however
we'll start with the X-Men so we'll get
introduced to Wolverine maybe Rogue
maybe Professor X Magneto and I'm sure
some of the stories will be put into one
as well perhaps they do a movie about
Professor X and Magneto's relationship
even though that would kind of be like
first class but it's in the MCU so it
would be different but ultimately you
have individual solo movies given us
origin stories of X-Men in this universe
or mutants I should say and then
ultimately you have an X-Men film where
they all come together that way it's a
giant huge event just like the first
Avengers film and then you can go on to
do it like the other Avengers films
where they come back together and
they're these really big events that
make fans super excited because they
only come around once every few years
and then ultimately you could have a
huge X-Men Avengers Fantastic Four
whatever event again like Avengers
endgame and of course Avengers Secret
Wars and I know everybody is hoping that
at some point in time we do get an
Avengers vs X-Men film and since the
X-Men are going to play such a huge role
in the new MCU you might be asking well
what is going to happen to the Avengers
and since this is going to be a soft
reboot we are assuming that some of the
old characters from phase 4 Phase 5 or
phase six will bleed over into the new
universe characters like Kamala Khan aka
Miss Marvel during the show Miss Marvel
we learned that she is kind of a mutant
so it is possible that her story goes
over into the new MCU where she might
actually end up becoming an X-Men and it
is of course possible that characters
like Doctor Strange or the Scarlet Witch
due to their magical powers could stick
around in the new universe as well right
now we're unsure of which characters are
going to be sticking around but we do
know that the X-Men are going to be new
and they're going to play a huge part in
the beginning of this new chapter of the
the Marvel Cinematic Universe heck
perhaps they'll even call it chapter 2
chapter 2 phase one hit me up Marvel I
got ideas but let me know what you think
about all of this in the comments down
below do you like the idea of a soft
reboot does this sound good to you or
would you have it some other way and if
you would please let me know what that
way would be so don't forget to
subscribe so you can keep up on all the
latest MCU news and of course like the
video and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items we pick one winner at
the end of each month and the winner
gets to pick one item you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof